a flashbulb memory is a memory that
forms kind of as though a flash is going
off in a camera and you imprint a
picture in your mind of what's going on
at a particular moment in time that was
a term that was devised and coined in
the 1970s by the late social
psychologist Roger Brown who did a study
on people's memories of the
assassination of President Kennedy and
he found that people had extremely vivid
memories of where they were when they
heard about it what they were thinking
doing who they were with what they did
next and he found also four other
significant events like the
assassination of Martin Luther King
people had formed similar memories and
he concluded on that basis that highly
significant events sort of imprint
themselves into your memory and you're
going to always remember them it turns
out that and this is kind of a natural
belief that this is this shouldn't
surprise us for example we all probably
have a pretty good idea where we were
when we heard about the terrorist
attacks on September 11 2001 I have a
good memory of it I actually heard about
on the Howard Stern Show of all places
when I woke up I was in graduate school
so I woke up late those days and I
actually tuned in the Howard Stern Show
and that's how I found out about it at
least I think that's how I found out
about it that's how I remember it when
people have actually done clever studies
on flashbulb memories to look and see
where there are intuitive beliefs about
how accurate they are match up with
their true accuracy they find out that
flashbulb memories are not really any
more accurate than ordinary everyday
memories one especially interesting
study was done by Ulrich Nasser who had
also done long ago the study that
inspired our gorilla study he actually
after the Challenger Space Shuttle
exploded in 1986 the very next day he
went to a class full of students and had
them write down all this information
where they were who they were with how
they heard about it and so on and then
followed up several years later before
they graduated college and had them
recall it again found out that their
recall years later did not really match
what they had written down the day after
but their confidence was extremely high
they were sure that that's exactly how
they remembered if they had no doubt
whereas of course they couldn't tell you
what they were doing the day before the
Challenger exploded to the day after the
Challenger exploded just like all of us
probably have no memory of what was
going on in September 10 2001 so the
thing about flashbulb memories that
really makes them
sort of
deceptive is that there no more accurate
than ordinary memories they're subject
to the same kind of distortions that
just happened in time to all of our
memories but we're more confident in
them because they're so vivid and
they're so detailed and we sort of place
really unwarranted faith in them
um memory is not a complete fraud we do
remember some things it's not as though
everything in our memory is a distortion
and inaccurate and so on one thing
that's been learned from a lot of
research on memory over decades is that
memory for the gist of something for the
main idea is much better than memory for
specific details memory for details can
change and fade over time memory for
sort of main ideas themes emotional
experiences probably nobody really
missed remembers how they felt on
September 11th but they might miss
remember where they were who told who
told him about it and details like that
especially the farther away they are
from the epicenter of events but they're
not going to forget how they felt on
that day as easily so sort of the
overall message often comes through but
the details can change and fade over
time the problem of course is that we
don't realize that so we can get into
big arguments over the details of
memories who said what to whom when did
they say it exactly you know what was
said before that what we said after that
think about how many arguments you've
gotten into over the course of your life
where that's what's going on and those
are kind of silly arguments because
nobody can really trust their memory as
much as they claim to in the heat of the
moment
a surprising fact about memory is that
our memories can be pretty weak even for
things that just happened a couple of
seconds ago and really a time frame when
you would think that memory should be
pretty good it's one thing for memory to
fade after a few years but it's another
thing for it to get completely erased
after a couple of seconds and a great
example of how this can happen is shown
in films every day every movie that you
watch has what are called continuity
errors and they're catalogs of these on
the web you can go and type in any movie
name you want and find all the mistakes
that the film editors made now sometimes
they realize they were making those
mistakes but they knew that most people
wouldn't see them and in fact when you
watch movies you hardly ever notice a
continuity error because you're paying
attention to the plot and the action and
the characters and so on and you don't
notice that for example in The Godfather
there's a glass of wine on the table in
one scene and then when the camera comes
back to it it's gone and then when the
camera comes back again it's back again
um
but those are really sort of failures of
memory you looked at that scene and you
felt like you were taking it all in and
then when you came back to it from a
different camera angle or after a cut
you didn't bother to match up your
previous memory to what was then on the
screen afterwards or you didn't even
store as much detail about it in the
first place as you thought you did you
might not have actually even stored the
information about the wine glass even
though he paid attention to it at the
time so it's one thing to pay attention
to things and notice them but it's a
whole other thing to actually get them
into memory and this phenomenon of
continuity errors and how many changes
we can miss as a video cuts from one
angle to the other from one scene back
to another illustrates another aspect of
the illusion of memory